Farm businesses have enjoyed
exceptionally high prices and incomes over
the last ten years. Even this year, with
somewhat lower crop and livestock prices,
farm cash incomes are well above their
long-run average. In fact, since the early
1980s, households that own and operate
farm businesses have consistently
enjoyed higher incomes than the average
American household. This is not your
great-grandmother's poverty-riven
"Grapes of Wrath" farming community.
Nevertheless, Congress continues to
funnel over twenty billion dollars a
year in subsidies to farm businesses.
Those payments mainly flow to the
largest farm operations, whose owners
enjoy incomes in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars. Many farm subsidy
programs also waste scarce economic
resources. For example, crop insurance
programs encourage farms to adopt
high-risk strategies and farm fragile
lands. Several conservation subsidies are
so poorly targeted that they have almost
no impact on the environment. So is there
any justification for continuing most
farm subsidy programs? The answer, quite
simply, is no.
So what do you think about
farm subsidies? Let us know in your
comments, and also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds. And be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI